[Musique]
je tends l'oreille
dans la première la première analyse
c'est que on voulait absolument partout
pour la promotion d'un film ça c'est pas
une anomalie
alors que vous n'êtes pas les
réalisateurs de ce film donc je me
tourne vers alain berbérian j'ai quand
même le dire qu'on ne vous a jamais et
qui est normalement se dit qu'on a vite
dans les émissions ça bah ouais mais va
bosser un peu tiens j'ai averti michel
geay mais alors il le dire hier il ne
parle pas français
ce qu'une non se tue non il faut d'abord
s'occuper d'eux du matin au soir il faut
s'occuper du fils il faut s'occuper
d'eux des 50
les techniciens qui assurent le film
donc c'était istres un peu dur mais
comme il était très sage je m'en suis
assez bien sorti au moins le temps de
tournage on a eu douze semaines de
tournage grâce à mon producteur charles
gassot qui nous a quand même qui nous a
donné des moyens assez confortable pour
parce que quand voix oui ça soit vu les
décors et les volailles et beaucoup de
notre personne dessus
j'ai même costume durant tout le film à
vous travaillez travaillez avec des nuls
depuis depuis longtemps moi j'ai
commencé en moi j'étais à canal donc
j'avais commencé à monter objectifs du
gt monteur à l'époque puis j'en ai eu
marre au bout d'un moment j'avais pris
une année sabbatique en 88/89 ils vont
appeler pour réaliser des fausses pubs
et les fausses bandes annonces et puis
ça a été un peu je pense une espèce de
coup de foudre
je suis resté avec eux et dans le type
de complicité que vous avez avec eux
mais que vous aviez sur des sur des
séquences courtes parce que les sketches
les fausses pubs les bandes annonces
étaient assez quand même des choses qui
durent deux trois minutes
et passer comme ça la longueur d'un long
métrage ça ça change des choses y
compris dans les rapports dans les
rapports de travail non dans les
rapports non parce que
je craque quand ça a été bien rodée
entre nous de 89 à 92 on est quand même
beaucoup bossé on se connaît vraiment
très bien
ils savent ils savent comment travailler
avec moi et moi je sais très bien
comment comment les ménager ou comment
les dirigeants pour ce ménage
vous savez toutes les stars il faut les
ménager un peu donc non non mais sur
deux et ce point de vue là non si le
scénario est tellement bien écrit enfin
bon il ya quand même arrivé il ya un
rythme il ya le faire il me suffisait de
transit dans des salles ils n'arrêteront
plus il a pas parlé bon pasteur il a
continué leur excuse moi on connaît ses
parents c'est pour ça qu'on l'a engagé
voilà c'est ça la raison enfin charles
gassot réalité d'un producteur sérieux
vous prenez guérissent mais généralement
mesuré gala qu'est ce qui vous a poussé
à vous lancer dans une aventure aussi
incertaine mais bon soir à bâle après
mais il ya aucun film certains il ya au
calme certains il est moins certain de
rien mais justement cela était tellement
ovni maintenu d'ailleurs de nulle part
dit au moins on s'est dit au moins là il
ya un coup à jouer et il était c'est
vrai il a raison ce qui était
parfaitement bien écrit c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on assiste à l'éclosion
de trois nouveaux scénaristes en france
et aujourd'hui on voit ça fait pas de
mal ça dérange pas mais d'avoir des gens
nouveaux qui arrivent donc cinéma je les
lui avec la première fois qu'une peut
revendre terrible parce que c'était bien
donc quand est ce qu'ils vont faire le
coup jusqu'au bout aux scénarios pop et
après la tuerie la lecture était pleine
de plaisir et français dit on sépare
avant de fermer ça prend la vie comme on
sait pas comment le faire parce que
c'était tout d'un coup une comédie
française n'étaient pas habituelles en
ce sens qu'elle demandait énormément de
moyens sur des effets spéciaux par
exemple choses qu'on ne traite pas
forcément par les pompiers en france
demandé une bande d'une bande son
ce sur quoi on n'est pas beaucoup
d'argent en france sur les films parce
qu'on se dit c'est pas grave on verra
plus tard
en gros ils voulaient inscrire leurs
deux comédies et on n'avait pas
l'article en réserve en france pour moi
on s'est dit on va y aller on va on l'a
fait mais c'était cet intéressant moi je
regrette absolument rien d'ailleurs le
prochain et est à leur disposition et le
studio après 17 oui c'est ça c'est déjà
signé même sait quelle confiance
vous avez cette fois remanié le scénario
c'est ça que j'ai lu ça dans a pris le
même et on a réécrit cette fois la
photocopieuse donc et vous avez mis un
an pour écrire tout ça est ce que c'est
pas un peu trop à bout du havre le peu
de connerie tchèque pour deux mecs
kishiba on a mis un an
non mais bob sais pas quelle est la
scène dont vous êtes le plus fier
peut-être chacun chacun à un autre
chantal la plus la pluie battante
moi j'aime bien la scène de la poursuite
j'aime bien la scène de la carioca avec
alain et d'amour j'aime bien la scène du
west avec gérard darmon que je fais ce
genre darmon pascal et plein de
conneries au niveau des dialogues ya
plein de scènes que j'aime dans le fait
j'aime bien gore aussi dessus du début
c'est le nommage un peu quand même
au cinéma à sens et que vous aimez ça a
fait clic la série z
ouais un peu aux éclats doute à d'autres
films il ya plein de clins d'oeil on a
essayé de rendre hommage au cinéma qu'on
aime bien qu'un cinéma d'action ya même
des clins d'oeil à elia kazan qui a créé
quand même l'actors studio
voilà comme nous on joue comme des
saucisses en a créé d'accord saucisse de
strasbourg
oui c'est un peu sur les quais
transposer sur la croisette mais tu as
vu moi un moment chez en tee shirt on
dirait bandeau ouais mais géré mais bon
le riba ouais je crie pas obligés crier
adrienne ce qui à notre fils m'ont plu
[Rires]
donc voila moi mes scènes préférées
salle où je suis seul je dire ce que
personne à dire à celle où je me préfère
je m'aime beaucoup
et le fait de jouer un rôle d'un rôle de
star dans un film qu elle n'a pas été
trop dur non mais tu sais j'ai pris 700
grammes pour faire ce rôle donc s'est
fait un peu à la de niro giresse à ce
poids tout en ayant des scènes très
dures parce qu'il ya pendant deux jours
j'ai mûri j'ai décrit pas son regard
déjà dit absolument parc du one man show
on n'a pas fait tant des missions que ça
on avoir deux émissions de télé
retrouvent pour la finul par ailleurs
est la tienne qu'est ce que c'est une
marque en plus m6 soit la m6 soit la
3ème journée
ces barres quand on hallucine et
téléviseurs
par contre il résuma qui vient de faire
une émission sur les gens qui font rire
c'est pas des gamins vous n'étiez pas là
non non mais on fait pas non mais t'es
canal et fayard triste et il faut être
félé commis trice et du rappeur pas fait
ça encore on fera ça après demain on va
regarder c'est ce que demain vous seriez
vous serez jetés pas dans une pizzeria
des champs-elysées vers 2 heures de
l'après-midi on attend donc lorsque
sharga serait d'un producteur très
généreux qui ne semble donc si vous
voulez faire une émeute ou demain mais
ils ont dit à viard vers 2 heures
d'après midi avec les yeux évidemment
braqués c'est important évidemment de
savoir s'il y aura du monde
vous venez venez en famille et tout ça
il faut le dire cette fois quatre fois
oui mais tu sais pourquoi on dit la même
chose
non parce que les gens nous posent sur
la même question
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]